okay roblox reported a huge quarter in
q3 doubling revenue year-over-year to
509
million dollars full disclosure
my wife bought
i don't know how much but she bought a
bunch of roblox because she believed in
it and uh i think she got in at the ipo
which was like 45 or 50 bucks
so uh i guess i have
a bias here towards this stock not
really but uh i'm happy for her that she
made that bet she's got you know she
made the bitcoin bet too at a hundred
dollars so i give my wife a lot of
credit um
their uh shares jumped thirty percent in
after hours trading
it's now at a hundred bucks a share
that's a 13 billion dollar increase in
their market cap
crazy days right now folks 57 billion
dollar market cap big takeaways um
roblox users are insanely engaged
some back of the envelope math here
because
it's kind of hard to understand but
based on our analysis the number of
hours people are engaged in this
platform is bonkers
they had 11.2 billion hours of 28
year-over-year now
11.2 billion hours
in a 90-day quarter right
and you divide that by 47
million daily active users
you get an average of 236 hours per user
in q3
again 90 days
if people use the service
for
60 days that would be four hours a day
if they did it
every single day it would be 2.6 hours a
day
that's a lot of time on a platform um i
i
am stunned by that but in some ways not
i mean if you look at people who are
addicted to twitter they're on there for
more than an hour to a day so
i'm not sure if you know this back of
the envelope math works out but uh
you know in terms of there's developers
on the platform and people building
stuff if you don't know roblox is a
video game platform where developers can
create games inside of the app they went
public via a direct listing on march
10th they sell an in-game currency
called uh robux uh which allows people
to buy games and outfits you know all
that kind of stuff that
people are talking about now with nfts
being
um you know so special that you could
actually take your character's abilities
or outfits and move them from one game
to another that isn't happening yet but
that is the promise of this new
metaverse if you think about the
metaverse not as a
vr or ar headset just as a 3d world that
would be represented on a 2d monitor
they also have something called roblox
premium which is a monthly subscription
and creators and developers on roblox
can earn money and they earned 130
million in q3 which is a 52 year over
year
roblox takes 30 just like apple uh and
so
this is pretty uh staggering in terms of
the earnings for these games in these
platforms revenue of 509 million that's
a that's a lot of money when you think
about it
and these have to be incredibly
incredibly high margin businesses
total bookings uh which include some
deferred revenue with 637 million what
that means when you hear deferred
revenue somebody might buy the year in
advance so they might have more cash
coming in a quarter and then they will
do something called uh
accrual based accounting where you
spread those payments out and you get to
get credit for them each month or
quarter
uh depending on
how you've set it up
they lost 74 million uh that's up 55
year-over-year i'm not sure what the
total cost is here for this business
they have 1400 employees and that's up
66 percent year over year revenue per
employee for q3 was about 355k so i
guess they have a they have a lot of
employees to run this business you got
to think they could run this business
with half as many employees and it would
be printing money they're obviously an
investment mode
eighty percent of their employees are
either engineering or product focused
according to roblox if you look at their
dows 47 million uh that's up 31 year
over year just that just a hair above 47
million
their average booking for daily active
users is
13.49 that's down year over year in
other words if you have um you know 500
million uh in revenue in the quarter and
you have almost 50 million folks just
over ten dollars per user per quarter
which means per year we're talking about
you know close to uh 50 bucks a year
pretty amazing when you think about it
that is some serious revenue and that's
year after year these folks are going to
stick around so
i am much more uh bullish on roblox when
we compared it i
thought it was more of a hit based
business but this developer ecosystem is
obviously
starting to thrive and when you see
revenue double like that uh clearly i
underestimated the impact of those
network effects
i know fortnite has over 100 million
people using it every month so
there does seem to be this ability to
hit 100 million people using a platform
a quarter so this could definitely
double all right and looking at the
wikipedia there is a page you can look
it up yourself a list of most played
video games by player count
player unknowns battleground and
crossfire two free to play games both
owned by tents that have over a billion
users dungeon fighter 700 million
users as of may 2020
just looking down this list minecraft
600 million
uh users as of november 2020 that's
pretty amazing
pac-man doodle i've never heard of this
uh
the pac-man doodle from google i guess
uh 500 million peak daily players in may
of 2020 candy crush saga hit 500 million
players so clearly you know you can get
to hundreds of millions so if we look at
roblox here they had 202 million peak
monthly
uh players according to wikipedia on
april 2021 the number we gave you before
47 million is their daily active users
obviously you get a much bigger number
by the people who don't play every day i
wonder if that means they could double
that triple it i mean it's possible i
guess the upper limit here seems to be a
billion so if we gave them credit for
hitting in between those two numbers 200
and a billion
uh that would be plus 400 million do
they get to 600 million monthly which
means they could triple
uh their revenue so it does seem like
they're on the trajectory to to do
something similar to that and get to
minecraft's number which is 600 million
that to me would seem to be
a pretty amazing run and that means the
stock
would
be
triple or the revenue would triple and
that seems plausible to me i don't know
where the natural audience limit is or
if they would have to you know get more
people into uh video games for this to
to go beyond that there seems to be a
natural audience for these and another
thing to consider in all of this is
there could be other business model
innovations that occur that generate
more revenue obviously they're selling
in-game
items they're also have a premium
subscription and if they embraced nfts
uh or a marketplace where people could
trade their goods that could give them a
little bit of lift and
i wonder if roblox users when they grow
up if there's going to be
other games
that they would want to play i know a
lot of roblox players came from the
minecraft ecosystem and then once you
move from one to the other i'm not sure
if you go backwards that'd be an
interesting question uh if we if
somebody could find the data on that but
congratulations to the roblox team
it's time for another r crowd deal of